fahren gemacht den er sollte und jetzt
explodiert creeper sehr schön
ok direkt in ihren eigenen reihen ist
der kriegszone
herzlich willkommen zur zweiten folge
von community clash mit sturm waffel was
geht und ich würde sage ich gleich
ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt in
unsere eigenen channels checkt auf
staffel sicht aus link in der
beschreibung und dann geht es nicht link
in der beschreibung so leute seid bereit
und co wir machen auf krass ok es ist
mal wieder sehr beeindruckend wie viele
leute reinkommen
dann dürfte wahrscheinlich auch leichter
kann gestartet werden
und dann geht die zweite runde community
care schloss ich bin wirklich sehr
gespannt wie wir verfahren können und
habe ich sagen sie uns gleich wieder
es geht los auf die karte alle werden so
allmählich teleportiert und los geht's
okay ist wieder richtig episch man sieht
schon wie alle hier losstürmen
sturm ist ihm hat ein spieler mehr wie
es aussieht da wurde am ende jetzt
gesplittet weil es eine ungerade anzahl
von spielern drin war aber halb so wild
ich schaue mal dass ich möglichst aus
den fehlern meines ersten spieles lerne
geht doch ich hab die sounds ein
bisschen leise ich guck mal ich möchte
mal ein bisschen lauter
okay ich bin grad um videos musik sounds
machst du mal ein bisschen lauter
perfekt ich schaue dass ein bisschen
daraus lerne und jetzt hier am anfang
gleich mal ein paar merkels mache ich
habe wieder eine relativ überschaubare
anzahl an spielern gewählt und nicht
direkt 200 weil das halt ja noch die
kleinere karte ist die nächste karte
kommt ja dann auch bald aber ich bin
sehr gespannt wie das ganze jetzt die
läufer laufen wird ob ich vielleicht
diesmal gewinnen kann hat er mich
natürlich ganz gut in die gegnerischen
reihen geführt hier der der gut aber ich
schaue mal okay ja ich glaube ich werde
sterben aber mein community kämpft sehr
gut auf jeden fall also wir sind jetzt
ein spieler im vorsprung sozusagen
aber wo richtig kopf an kopf noch ich
bin ich gespannt also ist ganz normal
dass man am anfang stirbt aber ich freue
mich auf jeden fall richtig letzte folge
hat mega bock gemacht
diese folge wird auch cool und ich freue
mich auch auf stage gespannt weil gerade
so etwas war oh angeht ist man so etwas
wollen wird schumi nicht uninteressant
denkmal und ja also mal sehen was das
beste zu machen ist so erstmal ein
pakets abstauben okay ich habe direkt
ein abgeschlossen könnt alter wert chaos
so aber ich muss wirklich sagen lag
mäßig sehr sehr gut geregelt
er geht auf mich also es ist an sich
klar der reiz ist da dass man auch ein
könig geben uns ja auch ein bisschen ab
von rüstungs aber wir halten westerham
gegen tages aber andererseits bringt das
halt dem team nicht so wirklich viel
aber ja leute machen und trotzdem gerne
auf den königin okay zwei leute habe ich
gespielt zweimal gestorben ist nicht so
super gut aber ich glaube als könig
kannst du eh nicht so die übertriebenen
kids machen am anfang
ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt wie das
jetzt wird gegen sturm
die teams sind so ausgeglichen
auch noch mal entscheiden weil das ist
wirklich krass vielleicht ist ja nicht
auf aber es ist richtig richtig ist kopf
an kopf rennen gerade also beide
communitys kämpfen richtig stark radeln
und hier ein optimist wurde dem volk
kenne ich auch schon okay da wird schon
okay okay okay kommt komplett richtig
heftig alle jetzt geht sie aber ab alter
ich gegen fünf oder was mal schauen ob
ich vielleicht ihr ein habe ich
mitgenommen habe ich mitgenommen
ok und das sind deren creeper die da
sind da muss ich auf jeden fall weg
nicht dass sie hier explodieren
okay vielleicht hatte ich auch jetzt mal
die special items aus aber vielleicht
wäre es auch besser die sich für das
ende aufzubewahren aber ich glaube ich
komme jetzt mal hier trikots haben jetzt
fünf gekostet aber vielleicht kann ich
dann halt rapax niessl
vielleicht kann ich jetzt den einen oder
anderen kiel mitmachen
hier das sturm i8 ist es war am montag
auch sehr gut alter combo hoffentlich
noch viel bevor ich selbst von der seite
irgendwie und jemand anders aus dem team
weggeschlossen wurde aber ich habe
getötet drei akws trieb es gibt
natürlich auch extra punkte bei einer
street und mein team führt gerade ganz
leicht also ist aber echt kopf an kopf
all das sei spannend und ich weiß ich
weiß nicht wie viele kids sturm ihr
gemacht hat weil wenn wir jetzt wirklich
kopf an kopf sind dann könnte das
natürlich kritisch werden
wenn also wir sind ja die mäßig kopf an
kopf also da wird jetzt keiner irgendwie
30 punkte irgendwie für die
verbleibenden community herzen bekommen
sondern es wird wahrscheinlich schrieb
er okay und jetzt drauf jetzt auf ok
irgendwer hatte gab es für den kleinen
bug weil der hat nicht zu dem schaden
gemacht denn er sollte und jetzt
explodiere drin creeper sehr schön
ok direkt in ihren eigenen reihen ist
der körper gezündet ich hoffe mal dass
ich jetzt noch markiert man kann ich bin
auf 15 punkten schon richtig spannend
gerade auf jeden fall
und h verdammt ich kenne natürlich sehr
offensiv weil ich weil man ja als könig
rausfliegen sei es gab ja auch so ein
bisschen kritik so von wegen die besten
spieler sollten sollten ins ins finale
kommen aber es ist ja natürlich ein
format so was für youtube konzipiert
wurde dass das halt als zuschauer
spannend ist und da wäre es ja wäre es
ja doof wenn wir so nach zwei minuten
stehen könnten oder so da müsst ihr
einfach ein bisschen verständnis wir
haben das das da halt die unterhaltung
im vordergrund steht aber jetzt auf den
letzten metern haben hat die dekra name
gut ausgepackt hier richtig schön die
bogenschützen im hintergrund sehr sehr
gut wieder das machen dann laufe ich
hier mal rein
ok meist die haben sich ja auch hinter
den ecken verkämpft sei stark gemacht
leute leute leute mal scheint das was
der sturm hier so treibt ob er bei
seinen leuten ist vielleicht liegt man
ja gleich mal okay da ist oder doch da
wacker chemie und hat mich aber zum
glück nicht getötet das wäre natürlich
ärgerlich einstimmig getötet hätte aber
wo läuft deutlich besser als die erste
runde community clouds gerade ich glaube
ich können wir mal ein kit upgrade
kostet zwar zehn punkte aber dafür habe
ich jetzt scheint der brust platte
erscheint beschwerden zu was also ist
relativ teuer aber es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall bei spielern übrigens ist das
ganze ein ticken günstiger also da zahlt
man für ein upgrade weil das erst einmal
drei dann fünf dann sieben oder so weil
köning ist es 10 20 30 weil könig soll
natürlich auch nicht so komplett
übervorteilt werden
aber jetzt muss ich sagen
macht das die kranarm jedoch ganz gut
gerade und wir holen das schon ziemlich
schlag auf sturm hat mich in die lava
geboxt aber 22 2 also an zwei leben noch
einer lebt noch ok perfekt jetzt sind
wir im king battle ich komme zu sturm
ich glaube ich in schedule genau richtig
also ein spannender kampf fand ich es
lief so die ganze zeit kopf an kopf und
dann aber leute hab trotzdem für die
leute die aber gut gemacht ja wirklich
also am anfang das okay jetzt mal
shoppen gehen
auf der melone kannst du dir ein paar
feine sachen zusammen suchen ja wenn man
punkte hatten
hast du gar keine 3 ich habe acht kills
aber moment wie viel leben hatten wir
denn jetzt wir hatten unbegrenzte leben
ach so da steht die ganze zwei ich bin
die ganze zeit mega vorsichtig gewesen
so misst gut okay gut das wusste ich
muss ja nicht so am schlüssel ich hab'
ich brenne auch so ein bisschen das
nicht gut glaube ich oder du brennst
gerade hörst du nicht auf zu brennen
dass man nicht unverwundbar zu ist in
der zeit bis auch ein bisschen sehr gut
oder zweieinhalb herzen okay gut ich
habe ja sowieso erst ein bisschen ein
bisschen mehr
wir halten das nicht ich mache ich lass
mich nur ein bisschen so wie ich mich
wie es macht und achtung wir kämpfen
schon robert ich hoffe wir werden das
portal willst du echt du musst
mindestens nicht so oft heilen könnt ihr
also das ist unfair songs flori ach du
hast nicht fertig
wenn du du du wolltest
ok der playboy ist mein sichtfeld
projekt vorgestellt deswegen bin ich
auch besser geworden alter wie viel wenn
du mehr vom spiel siehst dann bist du
besser bist du auch stimmt das feld
hätten immer auch bei dir dass du dein
dass du deinen fv so niedrig ist
irgendwie sieht sich hier gerade nicht
altert combo aber wie sie kein problem
für mich
ja sie ich sehe da hat er schon respekt
hat er so ein schutzschild der nicht
sterben können oder nee das ist in
charge creeper ist eine geringe
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dies bauen und
die machen halt besonders viel schaden
aber den kann ich auch nicht treffen
oder du kannst ihn töten klar echt ja er
hat richtig viel gefressen so an die 15
pfeile schon recht ich bin jetzt so ein
bisschen in zwiespalt weil ich will
natürlich nicht dass du sagen kannst
hier kannte den spielmodus nicht kannte
ich auch nicht leichter lüge 55
ok also ich gönne mir hier gerade meine
gold apple lässt auch erahnen können
willst du wirklich keine mehr meine güte
ich hab's halt anders jetzt ein bisschen
schlechter gespielt aber kein grund dass
ich hier komplett abdecken sollte ich
das gut alles gut
die punkte mehr hattest du denn
irgendwie us 816 punkte ich hatte also
hektar davon eines anfliegen teilte 15
punkte aber dann halt 20 verstehe mich
von meiner tweaks community verlegt
hatten
die gewicht die wichtig man ja es läuft
wenigstens sehr flüssig dass das schöne
neuerung zum ersten mal hab ich auch
schon gesagt wir haben wenig auch das
sehr gut gelungen
props an mich
jobs an nicht das programm
enjoy enjoy der macht so hast du place
im radiosender oder warum seit november
natürlich kann nur energy berlin energy
weil ich bin cool
die höchsten wird auch weg erkennst du
kennst ev pegnitz taktisch spielen in
welche drauf und sterbe weil ich weniger
sachen habe oder ich gehe weg und
probiert und bestellt aber ich habe
jetzt wirklich schon großem einer
heilung sap was ich war das ist das
thema taktisch spielen die einzige
heilung die ich habe so wahrscheinlich
wusste das genau sind wissen wir so
richtig bloßstellen in meinen eigenen
modus
das coole ist dass sie nicht explodieren
bei mir die krippe - viel mehr bleibt
ich hatte zwei herzen noch in dem moment
da noch ein ding rein gehst ja okay gut
ich dachte nicht mehr dass so viel soll
das gerade gesagt hat ist das für mich
mal drauf gegangen aber viel
entscheidung vielleicht in der links
aber egal wir haben vielleicht noch ein
rematch wo ich das dann auch bombays
leif hamberger spielen kann haben wir
uns fast ohne tisch ja auf jeden fall
sehr cool das ist ein toller gast ja es
ist geiler modus meine güte
juli antreten kann man auch so spielen
also wenn ich jetzt mal anders machen
würde dann könnte ich auch das
einstellen oder geht es nur wenn du
musst das kann vielleicht sonst hätte
ich gesagt mach ich alles kann lokal
jeweils kranich geiler modus ist jeden
mittwoch gefallen hat leute damals gar
nicht rein was ja was da alles passiert
ist und links beschreibung bei 30.000
likes zeigt gerade die seien fusionen
ausnahme
das hat mir alles ein problem damit wenn
die füße sehen wollten auch nach oben da
bist ein paar fuß 40 leute da gilt das
gleiche